реєстрація
ран кого-кого німецькі торгової палати
дранку львова тут стартувавши німецькою
український бізнес форум 4 міністрі їх ні
заступника це сам волво українського
уряду велика делегація прилетіла з
києвом берлін супер канати не травневий
бізнесменів вкладу ти простіше в Україну
затікала у нас у німців на бізнес
форум зареєструвалася в 2 чудовисько
підприємливий нижче чеку валось близько 6
сотень людей бізнесмен month and заєць на
форум приїхавши на ще надходити та
а по скаже я його фірма в Києві майже
тисяч років ви рубля івеко не рами
жебрак і давно патча весь конфлікт з
містером та під актив темою за словами
знову приймати ти вимагаючи з
несправедливо був цю суму зосима
документів та бізнесмен прямо на форумі
поспішай підходити до палуби фіскальної
служби України а потім
і практично до шкірного нападу тут
міністра висновку ти бізнес киева зайти на
хоче алла профі складу період
інвесторів вашу ряд сміттярі клава тася
про середній бізнес просі mini pet
спадкоємство complies німецькі інвестори я
кіріш на іноземних підприємець
тихіше скажіть самій на фіскальній службі
користуйся можна владою з України та
обіцяти найбільшу годину реформа вати
ціль сектор за словами прем'єра яценюка
потрапив і тис ахав ніж ми наполовину
незабаром тил і лизнула роду бюрократично
агентство видом ства річки позики ластики
одним перевернем і зім'ятий того щоб
зайцю перевірку отримати взятки ми скоро
тили масу ліцензії дозволив
і 6 2 і радянське практики з контролю
над українською економікою вона не зникла
днів шиза узус три слова прем'єра
пробурити гузаль їх архамі
ми не сперечався і жодного нового олігарха
і не дали жадібним вченому зміцніть свої
позиції
на форумі підписувати угоду просторі не
німецької української торгівлі промислові
палати та методу допомагати інвесторам
через промені ти пиши капітал з vrn
найкращою рекламою для України стануть
успішніше на землю бізнес і як же
канцлер до негайно спочатку німецької
компанії з чим же пристави не в Україні
might позитивного тіней ти стовбур і не
їм розумом і результаті менше зроблено
метушні мачин і можете дістати шви звідки
слух це за своїх колег і з чоловіком від і
пальцем інфраструктура завезли тебе
морські порти сільської держави
пріоритет не свої репліки хоче залучити
вони травневих підприємливий до 3 доки
поспішати інвесту ватою переважно з двох
причин але марадин цивіна ситуація на
відразу проходить пояснюючи, що конфлікт
адже буває на п'ятий вигляд сотках
території України
дружба то людей на та розуміють що вина
конфліктна зона локалізована друга з
історичний феномен корупційний
торговими перевертнями мічені то україни
становить пак і 5 мільярдів євро сума
не варто знімати на марші так аж у б
2 бік трохи більше не показано купити
помилку роботу зони винний тур загинули
з'їзд з пішого дня тема рази через
росію терміни про але стіни будуть заявили
прем'єр-міністр України